So, I first started
with equipment.
Women's side of Giant Bicycles
'Liv' donated over 60 bikes.
Before the bikes were delivered,
I got the chance to
ride with the girls.
And it was probably the best day
that I've ever had
in Afghanistan.
I can easily pinpoint the worst
days I've had in Afghanistan,
and this by far is the best.
This is Mariam.
This is, you know, his
assistant, his right hand woman.
And she is the
strength of the team.
She is tough as nails.
She's been run over
by a motorcycle.
She has crashed numerous times.
She has been called
every name in the book.
She's been insulted
multiple times
over the past three
or four years
that she's been riding bikes.
These
highway
Afghan
f Kabul
are doing this with great risk.
But they're doing it
not just for themselves
they're doing it to inspire
other girls to ride.
So, I hired a little
truck, brought all the bikes,
bussed in the girls to
the province of Bamyan.
And we rode out.
We did a few laps
around the city
to kinda get the
feel of the bikes.
And played with the
idea of riding
together for
the first time
because we didn't have to
watch out for potholes.
We weren't, you know,
avoiding cars and trucks
and we looked--
Okay, what's it like to
ride in a peloton tight,
what's it like to draft
off of each other,
what does that mean,
how does that work,
lessons for me as well as a
mountain biker, not a roadie.
And the girls started
to look like a team.
For the first time, they
were riding together.
And while there's barriers
between me and Afghan men
that are eliminated
when I ride a bike,
the barriers that are also
there between Afghan women
of just... you know
a little bit of quiet,
little bit of
distance and formality.
When you're on a bike
that is out the window.
These girls are singing
Bollywood tunes
and dancing on their
bikes and shaking.
They're joking,
they're nudging each other,
they're nudging me,
they're shouting,
you know, teasing coach.
Acting like any other girl and
I get to be a part of that
in a way that I have
never been able to
connect with Afghan
women and girls.
Nazifa is studying
to be a midwife.
And is wanting to work
to save women's lives
and children's lives.
But she also wants to
compete in the Olympics.
And the reason that she says
that she wants to do that
is not for personal gain.
It's because she wants to show
the world that Afghanistan
and this is her words, "is
more than drugs and violence."
She wants to show that
there are opportunities.
And it comes back to everything
I have ever seen in Afghanistan
that keep me going back
and keep me believing
that change is possible, because
her face kind of... says it all.
That hope is always more
powerful than fear.
All of them have
said at multiple times
because I have always
checked in with them
one, as don't
continue to do this
just because I'm supporting you.
Make sure that
you're doing this
because this is the
risk you want to take
because you love it, and I will
continue to support you, but
you are never letting me down
if you don't want to
do this anymore,
if for some reason the
security changes.
And every single time each
one of them have said,
"change does not happen
by staying at home."
They realize that they
are on the front lines.
They realize the
risks they take.
Much more so than I...
could ever understand.
I get to go and come back here
because I have a passport
and I have a child here
and this is my home.
What's been really
heartwarming for me has been
while the team is
doing amazing things
to break open this taboo,
what's really phenomenal is
there's two or three
groups of girls
that are learning to ride
bikes without a coach,
without any male influence,
maybe a brother here and there.
They're banding together
and riding bikes
in an effort to change
it on a social level.
Their specific goal is not to
race, their specific goal is
it takes boys 20 minutes
to get to school,
it takes us an hour or hour
and a half, that's not fair.
We should be able
to ride bikes, too.
And so what happened
in Bamyan was
I was back there in Jul-- June,
and I rode with two girls,
who were riding
bikes and wanting
to teach others
to ride bikes
so that they could get to and
from the Women's University
because the bus
line had stopped.
In September, nearly 40
girls took to the streets
with t-shirts that
said, 'Right To Ride'.
And Mohammed, who is one of the
Men's National Cycling team
members was part of this.
And it shows that men are a
huge part of this equation.
That men and boys need to be
supporting women and girls,
need to be working together.
And that they are
working together.
I mean, this is probably
one of my favorite photos
of that ride.
There's an incredible quote
that has really stuck with me.
And I think that it really
represents the work that I do
and how I feel about
this whole campaign is,
"change happens when
those who are unaffected
are as outraged as
those of us who are."
And that's what it takes.
It's about realizing that
it's not always personal.
But that you need
to be outraged.
And that we need
to band together
to believe that hope is
more powerful than fear.
And that change is possible,
no matter where that is.
Thank you for coming.
( applause )